THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
JOINING US LIVE FROM WASHINGTON,
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON THE PROGRAM.
WELCOME BACK.
HERE'S MY TAKE, SENATOR, AND I
THINK IT'S FAIRLY SIMPLE.
YOU DON'T GET TO SHOOT AMERICAN
DRONES OUT OF THE SKY.
YOU DON'T GET TO TAKE AN
AMERICAN HOSTAGE TO DISRUPT THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD'S ECONOM
ECONOMY.
YOU DON'T GET TO BE THE NUMBER
ONE STATE SPONSOR OF TERROR.
YOU DON'T FIGHT PROXY WARS.
YOU DON'T GET TO TAKE OVER THE
ENTIRE REGION AND THREATENED TO
WIPE ISRAEL OFF THE MAP WITHOUT
EXPECTING A RESPONSE.
I DON'T WANT A WAR.
I DON'T THINK YOU DO EITHER,
SENATOR.
BUT THERE HAS TO BE A RESPONSE,
DOESN'T THEIR CUSTOMERS THINK OF
NO, SEAN, I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
IRAN IS EXCEPTIONALLY DANGEROUS.
TAKING SOLEIMANI OUT, HE WAS THE
MOST DANGEROUS TERRORIST IN THE
WORLD.
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE TELLS
US THAT HE WAS DIRECTLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DADS OF AT
LEAST 603 U.S. SERVICEMEN AND
WOMEN.
HE HAS DIRECTED TERROR GROUPS
ACROSS THE WORLD, TARGETING
AMERICANS, TARGETING CIVILIANS.
IF WE LOOK AT THIS MISSILE
ATTACK, THEY ARE TARGETING OUR
BASES.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS AND I THINK
WHAT YOU CAUTIONED IN YOUR
OPENING MONOLOGUE IS EXACTLY
RIGHT.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO GET INTO AN
EXTENDED LAND WAR IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO DO IT.
WHEN YOU SEE DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA LIGHTING THEIR HAIR ON
FIRE AND SAYING THAT WE ARE
HEADED TO WORLD WAR III, THIS IS
HYSTERIA DRIVEN BY THE FACT THAT
THEY HATE DONALD TRUMP, BECAUSE
IT USED TO BE THE CASE THAT WE
COULD ALL COME TOGETHER AND SAY
THAT WHEN THERE'S A TERRORIST
WAS TARGETING AMERICA, IN THIS
CASE, SOLEIMANI, HAD JUST
DIRECTED AN ATTACK ON THE
U.S. EMBASSY IN RECENT DAYS,
THAT TAKING OUT A TERRORIST IS A
GOOD THING?
I COMMEND PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
FOLLOWING PRINCIPLES OF PEACE
AND RESTRAINT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME, WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
SENDING OUR SONS AND DAUGHTERS
INTO HARM'S WAY FOR AN EXTENDED
LAND BATTLE IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE THINGS WE
SHOULD BE THANKFUL FOR LIVING IN
THE GREATEST COUNTRY GOD ABOVE
EVER GAVE MAN, THIS COUNTRY, THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, OUR
GREAT MILITARY AND OUR
SOPHISTICATED WEAPONRY, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE CAN CONFIRM
IS THAT THE IRANIAN ECONOMY HAS
BEEN IMPACTED GREATLY.
WHOEVER THOUGHT OF THE FACT OF
BRIBING KIM JONG UN WOULD WORK?
THE QUESTION IS THIS.
THEY HAVE THREE MAJOR REFINERIES
IN IRAN, SENATOR.
THREE.
I WOULD IMAGINE THOSE REFINERIES
BLEW UP ONE DAY.
THEY GOT THEMSELVES A DOMESTIC
PROBLEM, BECAUSE THAT'S GOING TO
RESULT IN MAJOR POVERTY FOR THE
PEOPLE OF IRAN.
IF THEY WANT REGIME CHANGE,
THAT'S UP TO THEM.
MAYBE WE COULD HELP THEM WITH
ARMS AND HELP THEM IN SOME WAYS,
BUT WE ARE NOT SENDING OUR SONS
AND DAUGHTERS THERE.
>> I THINK YOU'VE SEEN A
DRAMATIC SHIFT.
UNDER BARACK OBAMA, THE POLICY
WAS APPEASEMENT.
THE POLICY WAS TO GIVE OVER
$100 BILLION TO IRAN.
THEY LITERALLY FLEW $1.7 BILLION
IN CASH IN UNMARKED BILLS IN THE
DEAD OF NIGHT INTO IRAN IN A
VERY REAL SENSE, THE MISSILES
THAT WE SAW FIRED OR
PAID FOR BY THE BILLIONS THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION FIRED
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION GIRED
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION GAVED
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION GAVE THE
AYATOLLAH.
LET ME SAY, THE LAST THREE
YEARS, I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP, URGING HIM
TO PULL OUT OF OBAMA'S
DISASTROUS IRAN DEAL.
HE DID THAT.
HE TOOK ON HIS OWN STATE
DEPARTMENT AND MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION THERE.
WE HAD WAIVERS IN PLACE THAT
WERE ALLOWING IRAN TO SELL
1 MILLION BARRELS A DAY IN OIL.
THE PRESIDENT AGREED AND ENDED
THOSE WAIVERS.
SO, THE EFFECTS OF THESE
SANCTIONS IS HAVING A REAL
EFFECT.
BUT WE NEED TO STAND UP TO THE
AYATOLLAH.
IT'S A RADICAL RELIGIOUS ZEALOT.
HE HATES AMERICA.
HE LITERALLY CHANTS "DEATH TO
AMERICA" HE CALLS ISRAEL THE
LITTLE SATAN AND AMERICA THE
GREAT SATAN.
THE WAY TO DEAL WITH THEM IS NOT
THROUGH WEAKNESS, BUT THROUGH
STRENGTH.
WE SAW THAT IN TAKING OUT
SOLEIMANI THIS PAST WEEK.
>> Sean: YOU ARE RIGHT.
I KIND OF KEEP SAYING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT YOU WANT TO WHAT
THE COUNTRY OFF THE MAP AND THAT
WOULD BE ISRAEL.
THEY ARE THE LITTLE SATAN AND WE
ARE THE BIG SATAN.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT IDEOLOGY
THAT YOU ARE RIGHTLY DESCRIBING
EVER GOT A HOLD OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS?
DO YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT, BECAUSE I
DON'T, THAT THEY WOULD MARRY
THAT IDEOLOGY WITH THE WEAPONS,
AND THE WORLD COULD FACE A
HOLOCAUST OF MONUMENTAL
PROPORTIONS?
WE DID LOSE OVER 100 MILLION
SOULS.
>> I THINK YOU ARE EXACTLY
RIGHT.
IT'S WHY I'VE SAID FOR MANY
YEARS THAT THE BIGGEST NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT FACING AMERICA
IS THE THREAT OF A NUCLEAR IRAN.
THE RISKS ARE UNACCEPTABLY HIGH,
THAT WE WOULD FIND THAT OUT
THROUGH A MUSHROOM CLOUD.
I'M NOT WILLING TO ROLL THOSE
DICE.
A THEOCRATIC LUNATIC SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO ACQUIRE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
WE STOP FUNDING IT.
WE STOP THE DEAL FUNDING THEM
WITH BILLIONS.
BUT WE NEED TO BE ABSOLUTELY
UNEQUIVOCAL THAT HE WILL NOT GET
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
TONIGHT COULD HAVE PLAYED OUT
VERY DIFFERENTLY.
YOU COULD LITERALLY BE SEEN
MILLIONS OF CASUALTIES.
THAT'S NOT A RISK WE SHOULD
ALLOW.
WE HAVE AIR POWER.
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROJECT
FORCEFULLY ECONOMIC SANCTIONS.
THERE ARE ALL SORTS OF STOPS
SHORT OF SENDING IN THE MARINES
AND OUR MISSION SHOULD NOT
BECOME A SOMETIMES REPUBLICANS
HAVE GOTTEN OFF TRACK AND
THOUGHT THAT OUR MISSION SHOULD
BE TO TURN FOREIGN COUNTRIES
INTO DEMOCRATIC UTOPIAS.
I DON'T WANT TO TURN IRAN INTO
SWITZERLAND.
I THINK IT WOULD BE A WONDERFUL
THING FOR THE IRANIAN PEOPLE IF
THEY OVERTHREW THE AYATOLLAH AND
IF THEY ENDED THIS TYRANNY AND
OPPRESSION --
>> Sean: BUT WE ARE NOT DOING
IT.
>> IT'S NOT THE JOB OF OUR
SOLDIERS TO GO IN AND DO THAT.